the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
otherwise class announcements sprint
task lists due today hopefully I'll turn
them in plane is gonna check that out
and make sure that we have each team has
a new sprint test this turned in we're
asking for one of those once a week
because we want to know the state of
your game as it is right now it's a lot
of it is for our use to kind of track
where your game is going and how your
game is going the actual format you're
using isn't as important to us for this
last project again if you're using a
non-standard format at once we get to
the next product backlog presentation
which I believe is next week but I could
be wrong about that
it's in stellar we'll be asking you
about your project management process
what you've been using how it's been
working what changes you've made stuff
like that to know how you're tracking
what you're doing than when you're doing
it yep so today I've got a minute but
today we're going to talk about story
and video games then do you have time to
work in your class and then at 3 p.m.
ed Barrett's class is coming in got 18
folks coming in to play test your games
remember we did require you to have a
playable digital bill today please test
that build if that bill does not get you
the test data you need also test another
one so if you if you have a paper
prototyping you want to test that you
can test that concurrently again just
like before I'm having three
workstations open and each team would be
awesome it means everybody gets to play
the games quickly and get out quickly so
that you can then finish up working and
you don't need to test each other's
games so and actually allow the our
guests to test games first before you
start testing each other's games today
Oh any questions about procedures and
whatnots alright so we're going to talk
about stories and games this is a
lecture that I've adopted from a
previous colleague of ours Clara
Fernandez Vera um she studies she
studies adventure games she studies
games through the lens of theater so
she's got a really interesting view on
plays performance but this is much more
of a talk about what is usable for you
right now in the games you're making in
this class
I'll start out with talking a little bit
about bigger games but then I'm going to
move quickly into talking about things
that are more useful for you all right
now so just a question for you do games
tell stories yes I hope see you nodded
why how you did my lecture I'm done
thank you any other ways games tell
stories so here in cutscenes we heard
narrative we heard words weird pictures
yeah but oh yeah one more and we're yes
yes game books the the physical things
around games yes absolutely telling the
story through the mechanics which games
did you mention papers please
excellent
um so when we talk about games and
stories sometimes we think about these
you actually you're you're good you
mentioned some other types of games
Final Fantasy 13 Metal Gear Solid 4 both
games kind of derided for in certain
circles for the linear nough subs you
start the game you watch the movie you
hit some buttons you watch the next
movie you hit some buttons some people
like that it's a that's a one way to
play games it's one games one kind of
game that is out there not exactly the
kind of games that were making in this
class but also not exactly the kind of
games not the only way to tell stories
and games as you just mentioned to make
those kind of games like in this and
what we're calling them Triple A games
if anybody's heard that phrase before
Triple A just meaning expensive
blockbuster the Marvel blockbuster
movies are basically what's happened to
film Call of Duty is the is the game
version of that so they require many
expensive art resources artists sound
design as we heard an artist talk into
it I talked earlier this week about
how arts important and why art is
important and how difficult it is for
one person to do all sort all those
different kinds of tasks that are
required for a complicated game also
just to note that on those two games
that I mentioned previously usually
borrow techniques from cinema so things
like camera placement lighting visual
effects and sound effects a lot of those
things are they're borrowing concepts
from cinema that have been proven to
work in cinema and then just throwing
them in the game because they know they
work so one way a triple-a Studio might
think about making a game with story is
alright so it's this balance between
interactivity and narrative right and
there's this cost to think of that
triangle as the cost cost money to make
these games and that money's generally
are they're spent on people or it's
spent on people or time so people times
time basically and the idea is that all
right so we've got this interactive
stuff going on right here the player
presses buttons great we've got this
narrative stuff here and I'm borrowing
comedy and tragedy this is why when I
say narrative think back to your
Aristotle so plot comedy tragedy
melodrama a lot of the Triple A games
tend to just basically be big melodrama
pieces but it could be folk tales that
narrative could be sometimes that has
conflict sometimes there's not conflict
sometimes there's a dramatic arc or not
but yes do they say all right so we've
got to balance the two and how do we do
that
state of the art Triple A 2011 this is
Arkham City that's Batman his parents
are dead press X to pay your respects
you press the X button
he places down the roads you get a nice
little cutscene reward Award with reward
with it so you can see a little bit of a
movie going on of him you know being
grim and putting down the rose but you
also get a little achievement so it's a
reward it's an easter egg but it's a
crucial backstory to the character they
put it in the game they spent a lot of
money making done animation not all
players are gonna see it and when they
do see it it only lasts for a very short
period of time all right so that was
2011 let's it's 2014 we're we're we've
got really cool computers we've got xbox
one ps4 your state-of-the-art Triple A
2014 Call of Duty advanced warfare we've
got an upgrade
hold X to pay respects basically it's a
QuickTime event and we've seen QuickTime
events with ear with other games of four
if anybody's played heavy rain
if anybody's played the Shenmue games
Resident Evil games things like that
basically you've got a video footage
going on and you can press a button and
it will give you a new set of video
footage so there's a lot of animation
going on there's a lot of cost going
into this I think the hope for this kind
of thing why it's hold X instead of
press X is by holding X you're embodying
that action you know maybe you're
grieving maybe it's praying maybe it's
holding the button
maybe the longer you hold it the more
you grieve so maybe there should've been
a score that was counting down how much
grief you got but if you've read the
internet about about the game you
noticed that yeah it's hasn't quite
worked out to the way that they might
have thought it worked all right so you
don't have triple-a resources so why did
I talk about all that and you should
probably just give up on stories right
I'm gonna say no of course that's why
I'm talking about this for about another
45 minutes um but some games don't need
stories to be fun or have a meaning
anybody recognize the pieces on the
screen Tetris the tetrominoes of Tetris
is there a story to terrace some people
say there is and I'm talking about this
Tetris too there's not even color in
that you can't even tell what the touch
Raman is are once they hit the hit the
the pile they're just there and actually
that might be that I don't know I think
though that bottom of the that bottom
Rose the bottom of the bucket that's
holding it so r1 MIT Media Lab Janet
Marie would say that Tetris is the
monotony of the work day of putting
things in the in their places another
professor Jim gee over at University
wisconsin-madison
he says Tetris is an escape into the
very desire for order control and
workable solutions that we have all the
time some other less notable but equally
valid people on the internet and say
they know it's the story of life it's
never won it always has an ending and
that in
is your death or the everything just
piling up - note to the top because was
made in Russia some people might say
that it's a critique of communism maybe
or a sameness or of bureaucracy
although the creator the Russian creator
Alexia pageant of would say he does say
that that for him it's about playing on
the edge of your abilities and applying
to a life well-lived so the point of all
this stuff is people read patterns in
the most abstract things so maybe you
don't need story maybe he just gives
them give them some abstract naissance
and then move on tetris was made 1981
there abouts on that one they can you
three I should have put that in the
slide so that was you know 30 something
odd years ago what if they made Tetris
today
here's Tetris today or one version of
Tetris today why would somebody make a
Tetris game with story this is the
Japanese only Puyo Puyo Tetris so it's
taking two different game mechanics and
splice them together why would they put
characters in the tetris game what's up
it might yeah I mean people are used to
seeing characters possibly yeah any
others any other ideas yeah absolutely
yeah I'm actually were just talking
about this before class would Tetris be
able to would would you be able to sell
this today do you think this could sell
today you never seen Tetris before it's
the brand-new thing look it out maybe
you maybe it would maybe it wouldn't
anybody played the game hexagon or super
hexagon yes
does hexagon super hexagon have a story
okay then why is there a narrator and a
voice why is she telling you
how does she talk kind of robotic
there's a little bit there's a little
bit of store why is the character a
triangle the the thing that you're
moving on a screen
why triangle not a square or a circle
maybe I'm gonna argue that there's a
little bit of there's a what's that
there you go
this little little Hinson story there
yeah
merchandise actually yeah especially
with this one
the what do they call the the characters
when they make like Internet Explorer as
a character similar is it a Tomo
something Tanya
yeah it's Alton and and other L Tom
maybe all right so that's story that's
the story of that even better story
conserve a gameplay purpose I'm gonna
argue that pac-man has a story a
noticeable story right there's cutscenes
in miss pac-man but what's the story of
pac-man we're like where are the hints
of story there
yeah absolutely and why why did they
give the characters names why did it do
the why did why is blinky blinky and or
that his k and his character his
personality shadow absolutely they have
did they of deterministic actions on so
I've given him a little bit of character
but that's gonna help you to identified
one before the other like if anybody's
played the Atari 2600 version of pac-man
my first experience with it all that all
the ghosts had the same image you
couldn't tell which one had which action
type of action they probably actually
didn't have a different AI it was a
really difficult game for them to make
they had to make it in two or three
weeks I believe all right so what do we
gain from story this is why this is
where I come in and say this is what I
think it's always gonna give to your
games even if you're making a strategy
game doesn't matter what kind of game
you make you're gonna get something out
of a story we understand our lived
experiences of stories so providing a
story is gonna help a player like
understand what's going on in the game
if you think about you know what you've
ever done in the past you're always
telling it to another person as a story
the way you do the way you you're able
to memorize things often as you're
constructing stories in your head of
things that you've done it's events with
causes you're placing together you're
finding patterns and you're putting the
story in there that helps you understand
what's going on around you story can
help you explain the world to the player
it can also encourage the player to
explore it so if you've got something in
the game that's that's hidden later on
you want them to find it you can use
story to give them hints towards this is
there's this cool thing coming up that
you might want to check out on a
parallel level to explanation stories
provide consistency to the world so if
you've got various things going on
within your game the way you can kind of
massage the the differences between
things going on between the mechanics is
by covering that up a story or rather
embellishing and supporting it with
story rather than covering it up
all right so a couple quick videos um
when I'm talking about story games
especially in this lecture I'm mainly
talking about games with story not story
driven games the games we talked about
earlier those were story driven games
this
God please forgive me what is she
talking about does anybody know what
what she's what she's saying there and
why is she saying it you might only know
this if you've ever played if he played
the game before knee really really into
the game so Matt yeah yeah so Cassandra
is sofa T is sister and they're fighting
for the soul edge for this demonic sword
that's gonna destroy the world and she
has to to fight her sister and kill her
sister to get to the sword in order to
either I think it for sofa tias versions
to save the world
why didn't she work with her sister it's
a fighting game who knows if I would I
meant to update the slides to something
a more modern audience might understand
in particularly guv legend does this
kind of thing a lot right there's story
moments going on in games you mention I
know a moment in the game does that help
you play the game better no it's a valid
use of story but it's not an efficient
use of story especially for your kinds
of games right it doesn't directly
connect the story doesn't directly
reconnect to the players experience of
the game but it is something players
like I like we talked about with
characters we like if we talk with
merchandise and in particular in
particularly for this game for
Soulcalibur why is so low caliber doing
this but Street Fighter isn't doing this
I'm soul calibur stands itself stands
apart from the other fighting games by
having these complex storylines that are
actually visible to the player within
the game Street Fighter does have
complex storylines but they're like
largely
fanservice or outside of the game
merchandise books things like that you
don't see you maybe see a little
cutscene or two at the end of the game
but not while you're playing it and also
to really enhance the single-player
experience of the game that's that's
actually how I know the Soul Calibur
series is I played it single-player
because they added an RPG to it that was
really basic and stupid but it made the
story a little bit more a more concrete
they took the RPG out that's when I
stopped playing the game because that
story didn't have any any there was no
reason for that story in the gameplay
anymore alright so
all right so I asked you about games
telling stories and how do games tell
stories and we're gonna say now is
technically games don't exactly tell
stories if you think about it like who
is the storyteller in a game you so it's
not storytelling it's story building the
the player the game the designer the
developer is giving you the tools to
build a story of your own and why we why
we say they're different so just to
compare and contrast storytelling is
continuous there's a one-way
communication it is from our author to
the player the order and in particular
the order of events and disclosure of an
information is determined by the author
of the game I'm gonna show you this and
I'm gonna show you this and now I'm
gonna show you that a story building is
more fragmented and it could be as
simple as I'm gonna sell you show you
this now you can go see all these other
things but you know I'm gonna pull you
back I'm gonna show you this next thing
and you have to see those two things in
order I'm in a more open oriented game
you could see everything all when it at
any point of time depending on when you
like it rather than a one-way
communication there's collaboration
between narrative design and the player
has anybody heard the term narrative
design before for the term or the titled
the job title narrative designer what do
you think that is on a company and let's
say rational irrational has narrative
designers she was actually a CMS student
for for infinite what would a narrative
designer doing in BioShock Infinite
a little bit I think Ken wrote a lot of
that Ken the the director wrote a lot of
that but they they touch that though
yeah mm-hmm yep
yep they touch that too the other thing
they do is you've got a level designer
and you've got a writer and right in
between you've got the narrative
designer on some companies isn't this
isn't for all companies this is just for
some on a particular says how I
understand how a rationale works right
is level designer creates a level based
on how a person's gonna play it how
they're gonna get through it how they're
gonna get from point A to point B writer
says here's the story I need everybody
to see and here's all the elements I
need them to see narrative designer
figures out where within the level those
things are going to exist and we'll talk
about that when we're talking about
Environmental Design point I'll point
out a couple places where a narrative
designer had an active role in that game
all right so I'm gonna say that we don't
need expensive cutscenes to tell stories
I don't know we've come up with a few
we've kind of touched on this a little
bit instead I'm gonna say is let's
reduce the cost of the game well let's
keep interactivity and narrative so
things a player does and the the story
that the player experience is about
similar so what tools are we gonna give
the player to build their story and the
where we give them the tools depends on
the type of story we're giving them so
there's two stories to two games that
the player that the player builds
there's the story of the world which
largely is seen and heard and it's
interpreted by the player and there's
the story of the player that's actions
that the player does and when I say told
Derek kind of mean built as well the
told is in that the player is telling it
not the so the world might be something
that the game is telling the player but
the story of the players is something
that the player is telling back to the
game or back to their friends or in
their own head so story the world it's
the world's history right it's the event
that happened in the fictional world
before the game starts you've got a lot
of control over all this your
as a developer you're writing all of
this for the player they're discovering
it and they're discovering a piecemeal
they're discovering it through the
gameplay so that story with a great
world that story becomes a puzzle for
the player to want to explore it could
be as literal isin mist where it
literally is a puzzle that you were
going around and solving puzzle here and
solving puzzles they're getting a little
snippets of background and putting them
together in your head to come up with a
whole view of what the the world is or
it could be things like I'm going to
show you with um with environmental yeah
so the tools are giving the player to do
that to do exactly that and these are
these are three tools that you have at
your disposal in your games right now
they're really simple and easy to use
probably the top two are title character
design and your environmental design so
we're gonna go through about four titles
I'm gonna give you the name of the game
I'm cheating a little bit because I'm
actually giving you the cover art for
the game I'd like to know what the story
is for the game so Zombies Ate My
Neighbors what is the story of Zombies
Ate My Neighbors about zombies what a
zombies doing they're eating neighbors
where does it take place in your
neighborhood alright
anything else they're coming for you
damn right yeah in the back
absolutely
hmm may you get the the kind of
distressed woman in the front she's
being chased by very are they slow
they're slow zombies right so these days
we have to kind of specified back in the
day they were always slow all right next
one the earth dies screaming what's it
about what's that space anything else
what's that war did here aliens
something yeah
anybody recognize the title yeah do you
think the game is based on the movie I
don't it actually isn't so the movies
from 55:57 I don't remember if it's a if
it's an alien invasion movie it's just
one of those things where in the 50s you
made a movie and then somebody came and
put a title on it based on what titles
were working that day what they licensed
it from 20th Century Fox but there's
these spaceships these these very 80s
looking spaceships this is actually a
cartridge for the 2600 looks awful but
um yeah the earth dies screaming at the
what happens at the end of the game
yeah arcade games back in the day they
had to how did they end they always
ended with you dying it was always about
throwing in another quarter playing it
some more getting more time that
actually came back over to the consoles
especially the 2600 days and we've moved
beyond that for the most part um in some
cases it's actually brought back in iOS
but yeah earth dies screaming all right
next one this is harder a mind forever
go aging ooh what's going on there
discovery yeah
absolutely whoo yeah have you played
this all right now it's good it does
help a lot but yeah that's exactly right
except you're wrong you're not a guy
right you're not a guy you're an alien
right yeah I probably spoiled it for you
it's okay
it's an infocomm game it's a text
adventure from 1988
so you're exploring text adventures were
open door go right open mailbox die from
groove and in this case it's it's you're
going to these you are going to do all
these different worlds and it's the mind
so that it had to do with and the AI
attaining sentience and figuring out
what was going on and what would
surround it what this the world was like
at the time really great game cool a
little bit of a tidbit of info for these
kind of games they came with these
things called feeley's so elements like
physical elements that were shipped with
the game box that kind of added a little
bit to the game because they didn't have
graphics to show you everything so in
this case it was a file folder a pen I
think was related to a company that
you're that you thought you thought you
worked for all right here's a more
recent game eight six eight heck what's
it about
what is 8 6 8 - h ACK yes the phone
number there's no area code right
normally we'd have an area code there so
it's kind of referencing back to maybe
the 80s you hacker maybe probably
anything else we can get from the title
alright we're gonna come back home to
use this example again cuz I love this
game so titles provide clues towards
setting character action even better
while you're thinking of your character
your title think about what it's like on
Google think about marketing right now
if you're making a game that's gonna be
marketed to somewhere can you google the
title and come up with
your game if you can you win it's very
hard for some of the games unless you
add a ton of money into it all right
next up is character design who's that
Sonic what does Sonic do he runs fast
what's he doing here yeah why exactly
right
Wow I could have written this out yeah
he's pissed he's like what the hell make
me move
you're not moving them on the
controllers is idle animation so a ton
of expressive expressiveness in this
idle animation it's maybe three or four
frames of animation of just him tapping
his feet looking at ya breaking the
fourth wall some really great stuff you
can do you can do with characters I'm in
that way yeah like why do we know he
runs if we were if this were like the
first time we saw this and this was
Christmas Day back in the time when we
didn't find out about games three years
before they came out you get this spiky
haired dude with big feet right he's
fast and he runs so yeah all right back
to eight six eight hacks I said I love
this game weird what is the player on
the screen what what element of the
screen is the player yes which one yeah
the top one right what are you well look
what it like what is it doing there how
do you think it interacts within the
system
yeah basically yeah do you see you see I
I kind of said there's other smiley
faces all right what do they do
okay so yeah yeah so those the the
purple one the magenta one the purple
one the red one those are bad guys
coming to get you
there's these little ones in the bottom
left and right there's a couple on the
in the top right that's a data data
siphon that's something you leave behind
so you're leaving behind a piece of
yourself or to claim space it's a
territory control game where you drop a
piece of yourself to consume the things
around it you can consume the programs
there and you can use the programs there
Wow but I really like it for this why do
you think I like it for this what do you
think what I'm talking about hackers I'm
talking to the smiley face what is that
what does that connote to you what I
hear it's fine yeah yeah yeah your
identity list right you're anonymous
okay all right so moving on character
design it provides clues towards your
actions and your verbs although in that
last example it was actually not very
good at that part but it does give clues
towards your background who you are what
you are why you are and then the feel
what's the feel of that game supposed to
be what like what's the feel you're
supposed to have when you're playing the
game question okay cool
all right environmental design is that
third thing I talked about this is
portal this is when you first start
portal it's very clean it's very
spacious except for that little box that
you're stuck in you eventually get out
but something happens and you see
something later in the game does anybody
remember where this is I would not
played it
what which level like three or four or
five or six or have you seen a turret
yet yeah okay all right close your eyes
it's it's 2014 come on yeah so this is
the cake is a lie later in the game it's
actually in a part of the game where
everything still looks really clean
that's as far as I'm gonna go
somebody left stuff back there and this
is actually something that not a lot of
players saw when it first came out and
then a lot of people other players told
each other about it later on so it's
also a game event which I'm going to
talk about later when we're talking to
the story the player but this is where
level design and narrative design meet
so the level is created there's a story
moment that had to be placed somewhere
the narrative designer placed it in a
spot that was hidden that was hard to
get to but still reachable and when we
talk about environmental storytelling we
often talk about there's been some
articles about bad graffiti and games
and just how how trite this this has
been used and we're trying to use that
we're trying to find new ways of doing
the same thing but it's basically there
was someone in there before you is what
happened there that's as far as I'm
gonna get alright so environment
provides clues towards what happened in
the past but also what's going to happen
in the future and a provides clues
towards the field so again what's what's
this game supposed to feel like alright
so moving on we've got the story of the
player so there's the embedded story of
the player and what I mean by that is
that's the story of the player that's
pre established by the game so everybody
played ocarina of time or heard of it or
seen it yeah okay so your link you start
out not knowing a lot about the world
and slowly the game lets you know more
about the what happened in the world
behind you you don't get to choose to
have this friend I don't think right
what's her name Starla Sariah the game
gave you this friend and actually later
on the other friends you give you get
the games going to give you those two
you don't get to choose to have them or
not and she gives you this ocarina the
ocarina is a very important aspect of
the game
so in this case it's this embedded story
of here's this object that you're going
to use it's going to be incredibly
useful for you and later in the game to
the point we're going to get really
annoyed by having to bring it up all the
time and play the same song all the time
but it's also part of the character
design it's giving you what your
capabilities like what are you capable
of doing in this case you're capable of
singing songs on the ocarina or playing
songs on the ocarina that do magical
effects within the game
there's also emergent and this is the
cooler things I might spend more time on
this is the result of the player
interacting with the system in this case
its Sims 3 and much of the systems of at
least Sims 1 I think still in Sim Sims 3
it's the entire game is basically based
on Maslow's hierarchy of needs which
I'll bring up the slide I think I bring
that up in a later version but basically
it is there's things going at the
sandbox game there are things you can do
in the game and the story that's being
told is the events and things that
happen to the characters based on
changes you make any environment you're
not all you're not gonna get the same
story over and over again you're gonna
get new new stories I'm some big
something like in this case the entire
game is that kind of thing in other
games it's a it's more of a smaller
aspect of the game it's a it's an added
bonus to the game so the story of this
player in either this case is usually
told through three things and these are
three things you can use in your games
right now game premise or the goal of
the game is your story right why are you
going where are you going
game events so things that happen within
the game either predetermined or
emergent and then micro narratives which
I'll explain what that is and I'm at the
end so here it is a premise again we're
at MIT so we talked about hacking right
I saw a woman length of Darwinian a
future contacting key to the quantum
game without
so through a lot of words at you but
basically every single thing inside of
that game is something you can do in the
game you can hack another person you can
create a virus you can download their
personal records you can change their
personal records everything will single
one of those things mentioned in the in
the premise in the trailer is a mechanic
that is usable within the game in some
form and its large it's like a lot of it
is a user interface it kind of looks
like a futuristic computer terminal or
an interface terminal made by the same
people if you remember we showed Def Con
earlier in the semester same folks
they're really good at that kind of
atmosphere and building atmosphere all
right so game premise that's an easy one
to get across basically it's just think
about all the things that you do in the
game all those things when when you put
them together one by one that is the
story that the player is going to be
telling when they play your game so
think of it in that case what they're
doing is are youth they're using a genre
convention and they're using some tropes
that you might already know tropes can
be useful tropes can be baggage trips
are usually baggage but your honor
conventions are great especially when
it's just I want to get you this theme
across to you I want to get this like
hard punch of you know exactly what you
need to do I don't need to explain the
game to you because you know what a
hacker is supposed to do that's where
those things are incredibly useful
oops give me my alright game events has
anybody played Final Fantasy 4 or 2 if
you play the original or the US version
I mean so there is a character called
Rydia the Summoner that is not what she
looked like in the game that was the the
illustration that she looked like she
looked like a very small green haired
person she is a summoner she has magic
powers
what kind of magic powers are common in
the Final Fantasy series what's the
three basics
yeah or blue or yeah fire ice and
thunder yeah exactly right
Moen so she's a summoner but she has
other black mage powers pretty common
most characters would have those three
carrots those three powers except for
her she hates fire and you don't have
fire for for a good part of the game
there's a moment in the game you're at
mount hob there's it's a nice Mountain
you need to get through yeah you can
kind of see ice in the background there
you need to get through the the cave and
there's a story moment and one of the
characters Cecil and the left there says
she's afraid of fire because her village
was destroyed in a fire and you and you
see the snippet of this early in the
game and you get moments that you she's
got this backstory where traumatic past
it's preventing her from doing a thing
again this is a trope that's pretty
common after this point they're all like
yeah you can do it you're awesome you're
great and then she gets fired now all of
a sudden you've got the fire skill for
this character for the rest of the game
any time you play the game after that
and you're using fire there's some part
of you that might be remembering this
story moment and how important the story
moment was and it's being linked back
into the game mechanics really really
well well but it always happens every
time you play the game that's embedded
that's always going to happen one more
video here is an emergent event has
anybody seen this video everybody
recognizes the game though yeah
there's a system within the game that
fire burns pretty much anything it
touches that's wood and it just travels
right you set this little system up you
use it the way you use it and in this
case he tried to tell a story of
building a fire and it turned out he
burned his house down you also see this
Minecraft the the creepers when I quit
what if everybody hears that hiss of a
creeper especially after you after
you've built something you've got this
tension you got this moment of panic
that's a that's a memorable game event
that you're gonna tell another person
after you played the game and especially
these days you might you're going to
record it on the YouTube and put on
online this was I think from 2010
because it's alpha build of Minecraft
alright continuing on the theme here's
the sims does anybody had this happened
to them in the sims they're just trying
to have a party they're trying to meet
their Maslow's hierarchy of needs right
they're trying to love and belong to
each other and build some esteem and
self actualize himself but they forgot
about the safety part of it and so the
event the oven blew up and their fire
happened and they all burned and died
common common trope is with the sims
it's another example I love anybody play
fire cry - yeah
you've so fire existing far cry tube I
love fire far cry 2 takes place in
Africa you're a mercenary you're going
to find a warlord and kill them at the
end of the game it's basically you're
trying to do um you have different ways
of doing that different means of doing
that you are in a savanna it's very dry
you can burn the savanna and it's great
and you can use that to get past like a
machine gun emplacement or set a trap
for somebody in game character not a
another PC but in game an early version
of this an early tests
playtesters set fire to the savanna and
then a couple few 10 15 20 minutes later
it said okay you won the game
what happened fire spread the boss was
set in the fire in in the in the end dry
grass
the fire spread all the way through the
game the the many many miles square
miles of gameplay and it killed the boss
and under the game I have really wish
they kept that in or a version of that
they ended up reducing the spread of
fire because of that and they moved the
character from that but that's a that's
a game event they could have capitalized
on that's an emergent that's a piece of
emergent storytelling it's going on that
people tell the story to each other in
developer circles I heard about this in
GDC the year after this came out that's
a great one so that's game events next
up micro narratives these are similar
but different micro narrative is
basically a little bit of storytelling
inside of the game that again really
really small so it may be it's an
animation this case isn't Jet Set Willy
and Jet Set Willy you are a rich guy you
made all your money in the previous game
by mining and you came home and you've
invited a bunch of friends to your house
you have this awesome raucous party and
you trashed the place and unfortunately
you rent you rent a mansion instead of
buying the mansion and you're trying to
go to bed and your landlady is just like
no you don't get to go to bed you don't
get to sleep you got to clean all the
stuff up
she doesn't say any of that though this
is all she does just she's standing in
front of the bed she's going that very
is this for the ZX Spectrum so a really
um I think it had 64k of RAM maybe you
could look that up maybe it's 8k it's
really small really bad keys we've got a
keyboard not a lot of graphics but that
version is actually a later version I
couldn't find this is the closest thing
we've found for what it originally
looked like but you can really sit
there's character design there but it's
also just saying you know no you can't
come back here
6
okay all right so now I have spewed all
this out what can you do with all this
and so the next I'm gonna show an
example of a game created last semester
by a team in this class for the final
project they made a game called sugar
rush what's the game about first what's
the height well I told the title sugar
rush what's the game about yeah candy
candy candy candy candy look at him all
that candy and it's a kid so title
character design all working really well
right there here's the game premise one
day strange leafy beasts spawned from
four mysterious portals and they
plundered the villages terrorizing
Candyland what do you think you're gonna
have to do kill the vegetables and
they're mean because look at them so
mean now when we say like we said don't
use cutscenes that doesn't mean we say
don't use exposition a simple screen
with a little bit of instructions like
basically this is we told them have an
instruction screen this was part of
their instruction screen they had the
screen that says these are the keys but
they're also this is what you do really
really useful that's what we want
something that fulfills that for your
game the way it's necessary for your
game the difference in a game that has
something like this and doesn't have
something like this is basically that's
a level of Polish a game that has a
little bit of exposition like this feels
a little bit more concrete
there's it just feels like there's
there's more it's more complete there's
more thought put into it it just feels a
little bit richer it's still playable
without it it doesn't need this screen
but the screen is really really helpful
and the gameplay itself but as mechanics
that are consistent with the design you
are a kid you are fighting a tomato
what do you fight with you have weapons
what are your weapons made out of candy
how do you heal yourself you eat candy
how do you make new weapons you combine
and craft candy everything's revolving
around that that premise of candy is is
the world you are the lone human being
in the
world that we see and so it's not like
Adventure Time you're not harvesting
candy from candy people but and you're
right and the weird thing about it I
think you when you kill vegetables you
take the candy from them maybe they're
stealing your candy there's the other
you are selling your candy so it's
plundering uh-huh they thought ahead and
yeah the health points what are the
health points called if you can read it
yeah really simple stuff really really
simple just theming it thinking about
what you call things how you call things
where you place things what your verbs
you're using all that ties into into the
game alright so another kids another
student gaming game it's actually made
by a larger team over the course of a
summer so they actually had nine weeks
to make the team make the game and they
had dedicated artists on this game but
there's a game called gum beat which we
have on our website there you are a
little girl going around chewing bubble
gum and this idyllic land that I don't
think there's no there's an information
sign up there if it said it's a keep the
place clean
basically gums not allowed it's not
clean but you go around you recruit
people you blow bubble gum in front of
them they say pop the bubble you pop it
they're like sweets I'm joining you and
then they travel they trail behind you
and you see on the right there a little
guard Metal Gear Solid style he's got
his own of sight line of sight if he
sees you he's gonna chase you down and
hit you early in the development someone
so if you put if you pop the bubble on
somebody like on your on your friend
they'll get stuck with gum if you pop
the bubble on the guard they'll get
stuck with gum and they'll not be able
to move but we found if you put the
bubble with the gum on the on the guard
and you have a guard basically look at
another second guard looking for that
guard for four people all the guard that
all the AI was was if gum attack guard
with gum found the guard attacked not
they didn't even think about this this
wasn't a feature they were they're
planning it just happened and it
happened in the space of gameplay and a
play testing just like that fire in in
Far Cry 2 except in this case they're
like that's really freaking awesome
we're gonna polish the crap out of that
and make that a key feature or a really
interesting feature in the game we're
not going to tell the player how to do
that but we are going to create a level
design that encourages the player to
experiment with that so that's where you
get that kind of gameplay so playtesting
is a way to discover emergent game
events so that's why we're asking to
play test your game especially people
who are not you is to see what you've
you've created this amazing possibility
space you can't explore the entire thing
on your own they might see something and
they might and not knowing what the game
is possible to do and what you should be
doing in the game they might come up
with some cool things to do in the game
so a play testing is key lastly I'm not
a student game but another favorite game
of mind FTL there is a story to FTL
that's really complicated actually being
used to try to emulate that core sort of
thing it's really hard it's a lot of
detail it's a lot of writing a lot of
thought being put into this randomized
event thing but there's a feature in the
game that I'm showing here right now
that is only used on this screen that's
probably kind of it was it was probably
a high price for them to put the feature
in can you maybe you can't read it
actually you can't read it that well
basically you can change the name of the
characters this is something that
strategy games have had for a long
period of time I think we remember
through XCOM back in 93 and 94 earlier
no 94 basically you name your characters
if you name your characters you might be
more inclined to make stories of their
gameplay so I've got my ship is the good
ship game lab with my buddies Andrew
Philip and Sarah and we're gonna be
awesome and take down are you taking
down the Empire I could never remember
empire a rebel are you a rebel are you
the Empire
you are the rebel okay yeah you're the
Empire you're trying to take down the
rebels yeah okay cool so one thing that
sometimes happens with this game though
some players are gonna optimize it what
did they name their characters pilot
shields engines who is dying
looks like the pilots dying how do you
know it's named pilot
I forget if you can I don't think you
can rename characters when you bring
when you when you bring them back onto
your ship I should have looked that up
anybody plays take a look at that but
you can bring it you can get new
characters later on whether or not you
can name them or not you might name them
you might not name them but either way
even if you give they'd spent a lot of
time and money putting this feature in
some players aren't gonna use it so what
do you do you blow [ __ ] up
the game is basically about traveling
the ship things catch on fire and
hopefully maybe they're not concerned
about pilots but they are concerned
about their ship so give them these
these cool little game events to keep
them going so one of the interesting
things about this kind of story is that
it's actually it's for all that you're
talking intime and money stuff to create
it but it's actually pretty cheap to be
able to let players name their
characters but it's even cheaper to do
it FTL dat the beginning where they
automatically named all your characters
like when you get a random human the
character isn't named human number 38
the character is named Fred or something
and that was actually originated from
their Kickstarter backers got to have
their names in which is kind of cool but
it's actually worth doing because there
are certain kinds of players who will
really get into those names in a way
that you don't expect I've got two
friends who really get into their games
one mark LeBlanc was playing XCOM and I
don't you probably only seen the more
recent XCOM I assume but maybe not the
old one so you can name your characters
or whatnot and it gives you some names
that you can use he had went through the
entire game and this is you know back
when the games were hard so 40 to 60
hours of gameplay and he had a squad of
super uber soldiers and they all had
names and he didn't quite have
personalities for them but they were
kinda like personalities and the vinyl
second to final battle one of his top a
squad people with got a broken leg or
something and he was like oh that's
really annoying because I'm going to
Mars tomorrow well all my guys were high
level are gone but I've got this guy's
really cool equipment like he'd got the
laser rifle of doom and the super uber
armor and so he went to his second
string of squad you know the guys for a
second level it's like you suit up son
you're going to Mars which for him was a
story it was all inside his head the
game didn't make that
the game did not make that story the
designers could not have anticipated
that story but in his head because he
was the kind of player who really tried
to personify his characters a little bit
it was actually a really big thing for
him
similarly another one my friends who
will probably come in for a lecture
later Laura Baldwin's playing
XCOM as well basically the same game she
in her head kept all the default names
the default name was a randomized first
name in a randomized lastname and in her
head when she saw the same last name she
assumed that meant the characters were
related now of course this meant nothing
in the game the game didn't care but
here are the two brothers here are the
two sisters here's the married couple
and so apparently in the final final
battle you've got you're going in to
destroy the big bad thing and the big
bad thing does horrible psychic damage
to all of your soldiers on the map every
turn and she was losing horribly and the
husband-and-wife team made it into the
final room it's a big brain alien and
the wife runs in to discovers the final
bat boss and it come it didn't you had
movement points so she went in and
revealed the fog of war here's the bad
guy
she is not enough movement points to get
to run away and the husband meanwhile is
out the doorway with the rocket launcher
and so apparently Laura the way she
tells it she spent about 15 minutes
having a conversation between these two
characters as the husband's like I've
got a rocket launcher get out of the way
hunting and she's like I don't end up
moving points fire the Rockets I can't
I'll kill you I'm gonna die anyway fire
the rocket and this goes back and forth
until finally she decides all right
boom fires the rocket kills the person
next to the big bad guy and wins the
game
but again this is because you had a
player who's very cooperative something
as simple as the names actually helped
now you can't guarantee you can get
players like that but those players do
exist and if it's easy to give them the
opportunity to have that awesome
experience that she tells 20 years later
do it it's relatively cheap
all right that's it for lecture any
questions about any of this stuff and
how it applies to your games
we have idea what they can do in their
game right now just thinking about any
of this does anybody thought about their
title at least
yeah it's nap okay all right so take a
couple minutes it's 2 or 3 right now
break working your teams whatever that
might be
we've got a test coming in at 3:00 so be
ready for the test at 3:00 I'll remind
you maybe five minutes or beforehand
so everyone raise your hand if you are
ready to test if at a workstation if you
are ready to test so I can count off 2 3
4 1 2 1 2 kind of all right we'll take
you get two more minutes Philip you want
to talk - yeah I speak to 2 ed students
I don't know if you're they scattered
around but it will help if you could
meet up here you wouldn't yeah so for
the first thing I want to say is thank
you so much for coming and you may have
overheard what Rick was saying earlier
this is going to be our first digital
play test for the games there are five
games some of the teams have multiple
stations and that's probably not going
to be enough computers for every single
one of you who are here so some of you
may be waiting in line but you know
please be patient with with us and we'll
hope to get your feedback on these one
or two games if not more it's good for
you to give us feedback while you are
playing the game so if you are the
students will get more specific about
the kind of feedback that they need but
you know if something is frustrating if
something is confusing if something's
intriguing or something you're really
you you really think something looks
cool or or is it an interesting decision
try to verbalize it so that we can
actually realize that something is
working or something's not working don't
worry about our egos at this point we
absolutely need the harshest criticism
that you can possibly give us at this
point because it's easy for us to change
things at this point on our project if
you if we learnt about the same things
that bother you two weeks from now
reversing all of those changes is going
to be harder so please please be harsh
now other than that yeah if anything is
confusing do of course vocalize it but
the people who are the people who are
making the game may not tell you what to
do next because they wanted to see if
you can
now if you can't figure it out that's
not a problem with you that's a problem
with the king but they need to be able
to see you sort of like muddle through
what's already there in order to figure
out how to fix it later so you do start
getting frustrated of course you can
always say I'm done with this game and
move on to another to another game yeah
that it's very database like I'm done no
no more that and that's absolutely fine
and be great to be able to tell the
other students why why you're done right
maybe it's because you you feel like
you've seen everything there is to see
into a game and that's very different
from I have no idea what's going on
that's two different reasons to leave a
game and they need to know what that
reason is
otherwise this by the way is creating
video games is six six six seven seven
three or CMS six one one it is a so the
course has joined humanities and
computer science and it runs for this
fall semester students actually work on
four projects for the entire semester
but the first three really really short
like tubing projects and this is kind of
like the make a big project so
yep this is Rick I'm Philip you all know
add and and and Sarah and bleeding are
over there just look why I do a lot of
us and we'll be happy to help
okay so play test asked workstations
stand up if you are a computer that
someone can come to to play your game
and testers in the back stand up if you
are a test station and testers please go
find a standing person and play their
game okay come up
so for improvement since I figured out
what to do I think the instructions are
clear